mr. Thompson I might ask you the same  question I XJ mother Lee did it kind of  have that 2015 2015 field going back  without having Kevin in the game with  the the offense that you are running he  said it felt like a little bit of  throwback ish it did like Steve Kerr  said we didn't have the ultimate luxury  tonight a man who can just go out there  and get you 40 on a whim so we had to  play a little more diligent with the  ball we had to be more crisp with our  passes we couldn't the and the room for  air was a lot less compared to Mike  Evans out there and I'm happy we won so  we can get some rest and get him health  because if we want to get this  three-peat we desperately need him back  you know he's our best players so we  dearly miss him and we'll hold it down  while he's out but it's not the same  without him far from it